do you know what happens y today I'm I'm
in the house my house is like a shopping
mall right right the front door kids are
always running in and out so it's a
sudden after morning and the doorbell
goes it's one of them doorbells don't
stop you ring it it goes ding D ding D
fancy house but three days he going Who
the hell's at the door and we have these
Tour Vans come around the PE Hills they
just take tours at your house now list I
thinking it's the kids for the some kids
to see my kids right and I'm sitting
there and watching the television you
know oh what's this now about 18 kids go
in she her room's upstairs on the left
and they go this guy's really cool man
there all these kids they looking around
my house
and really got a tourist he let a tour
you friends of our kids you
know sh do you get upset when Azie lets
tour buses of people into the house cuz
they think it's for the kids that's
funny I'm standing at
ja ising my
ass what a great story it's true really
he even wants us to go up and see his
daughter in
[Laughter]
bed